- [Adam Lefkoe:] Was D'Andre Swift underrated?
Underneath the star.
Can he get the star?
[Dramatic instrumental music]
Be a star,
D'Andre!
Welcome to "Underrated,"
the only show where professional athletes
get to improve their video game ratings.
And today we have the scintillating,
the super, the spectacular D'Andre
Swift of the Detroit Lions.
I'm watching you last year.
You can run faster than anybody.
You can catch better than anybody.
How is the gun, though?
How is the arm?
What kinda throwing do we have?
- I got an arm.
- You do?
- I got an arm. I do have an arm. Yeah, I do.
- OK. I looked it up.
You had one throw with the Lions.
You had one throw in college.
How many of those did you complete?
- Zero.
- Yes.
- [Laughing]
- Do you know your Madden ratings
for throwing?
- I don't. What is it?
- OK. I'm gonna tell you.
- OK.
- But I have the plug.
I brought him here to boost your ratings.
Let's get Clint in here. Clint?
Look how
official he is.
- Pure business.
- This is the Madden
Ratings Adjustor.
- Look like it.
- He said "Goodness!"
What do you think your short
throw accuracy is?
- Probably like a 50.
- A 50?
- Fifty.
- Clint, what is he?
- It's a 30.
- It's a 30? OK, OK.
- He looked that way
cuz he didn't want to believe it.
- [Clint:] So he's actually tied at 53rd
among all NFL running backs.
- 53rd? We need to change that.
We need to change that.
- We need to change that.
- Let's see what we got today.
- So you need to see accuracy today.
- I need to see accuracy.
- OK.
Are you ready to show him
what it takes to boost that rating?
- I'm ready to show you. I'm ready.
- Yeah.
- All right. Good luck. Show us what you got.
- Yes, sir.
[Upbeat bass music]
- All right, D'Andre,
we have a two-minute drill set up.
We got pinatas about five yards deep.
[Electronic pinging]
You hit one, you keep moving.
The more you hit,
the more your rating goes up.
So whenever you're ready.
He's goin' for the pig.
Gettin' his bearing.
Bang!
Next one.
Now the donkey. Drills the donkey,
and he opens him in half!
The unicorn. Boom!
Open him up.
- [Clint:] Just throw it out.
- [Lefkoe:] He hit Shamu in the fin.
Underneath the star. Can he get the star?
He can't hit this star.
Be a star, D'Andre!
All right, now he's moving down to the cowboy boot.
- He's throwin' right. He's goin' right.
- Right on the boot.
- [Clint:] There he goes.
- [Lefkoe:] Whew, and he opens the boot.
And now it is just the T. rex.
Drills Tyrannosaurus rex!
We have moved our way down the field.
You cannot miss in the red zone.
You're goin' for the Tiki Man.
I want explosions.
Ooh! First hit! Made his way down the field.
Got it done.
Tiki Man exploded.
How did it feel overall?
- [Swift:] Felt good.
Had to get warmed up a little bit,
but once I got going, it was good.
- I felt like some of the throws in early,
we were going low and to the right.
- Right.
- When did it start clicking for you?
- Probably about after the third throw.
Had to get in a rhythm,
but definitely was a little to the right.
Had to pick it up a little bit.
- This man has been writing notes.
He has been very meticulous.
So, Clint, are you ready?
- I'm ready.
- OK. Come over here.
Give me some shade.
- Sorry.
- Let me just get your overall feel of what we saw.
- Actually, pretty accurate.
D'Andre, you were able to hit every target,
and you didn't
hit 'em all on the first drive, but you hit every target.
- [Lefkoe:] Man. OK.
We wanted to improve his throwing ratings.
- Throw accuracy short,
because all the passes we made
today were
of the short variety—
- The short throws, yep.
- That's actually going up five points
from a 30 to a 35.
That puts you inside of the top 40 for all
NFL running backs.
That's a bump of 13 spots.
- Progress, I guess. Progress.
- And more importantly,
now I get to ask you
the question: Was D'Andre Swift underrated?
- D'Andre Swift was underrated in passing.
- Appreciate that.
Appreciate that.